gare saint lazare à paris première
journée d'une grande grève une journée
qu'on annonçait comme très difficile
pour les déplacements on va vous montrer
comment ça se passe regardez ici
normalement sur cette place ya
énormément de gens il y en a pas
beaucoup aujourd'hui si vous voulez vous
déplacer des trottinettes et des vélos
en libre-service il ya aussi des taxis
qui attendent ce qui ne fonctionne pas
ce sont les trains qui ne sillonne pas
la france ou presque pas et le réseau de
transport en commun dans la grande
région parisienne n'y a presque pas de
métro presque pas d'autobus non plus
tout ça parce que ses employés sont en
grève
bien sûr ça cause des désagréments mais
parce que les parisiens parce que les
français sont habitués à ce genre de
mouvement ils ont prévu à l'avance des
alternatives pour ce déplacement
j'habite à l'excès de paris donc
convenir gic ultra en fait et ça a été
c'était mieux que d'habitude et c'était
même mieux que d'habitude
j'avais de la place assise un mois
d'arrêt ça a été prévu toutes sortes de
manifestations chemin de fer l'art atp
tous même les taxis je crois à
l'aéroport mais maintenant c'est un peu
comme moi j'ai une heure et demie trajet
donc si tout le monde prend la voiture
va falloir partir très tôt le matin le
bus ils étaient pleins pleins on était
tous tirer les uns sur les autres
un peu galère pour venir jusqu'à saint
lazare j'ai dû venir à pied de la
banlieue de saint haon le banc du nord
et ils sont peu 3 le réseau routier est
moins chargée qu'à l'habitude
probablement parce que beaucoup de gens
ont décidé de travailler de la maison ou
encore de rester à la maison peut-être
pour garder les enfants parce que le
personnel enseignant est également en
grève donc beaucoup d'écoles qui sont
fermées aujourd'hui est français on
al'impression on fait des plans pour la
journée peut-être pour demain également
il ya la fin de semaine par la suite la
grande question que feront les français
que penseront t-il de ce mouvement grève
qui perdure au delà de la fin de semaine